I sense a great change in your future
destiny has dire plans for you my friend
I have plans for destiny hey everybody
we got some new infinity war to freak
out about I have an update on the
trailer and we learned what's going on
with Captain Marvel between infinity war
in Avengers 4 there's a new brand of the
Thor ticket giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video uh that's a new
winner at the end of this to the trailer
stuff first because supposedly Marvel
actually tweeted out Robert Downey jr.
account that there was something coming
on the 29th which is the Inhumans
premiere but now it actually seems like
Marvel may have already stealth
cancelled the Inhumans because they're
billing it as the complete series so
that just makes me think that this tweet
is actually just completely photoshopped
and this is not actually happening and
the infinity war trailer really won't
drop til we get closer to Thor so just
stay tuned for that but it does kind of
seem like they're packing the Inhumans
series up and putting it in that Indiana
Jones warehouse and hoping that nobody
goes looking for it again so if we see
the Inhumans again what might end up
happening is is they'll just pop up on
agents of shield and then maybe way down
the road in the movies but we'll circle
back around to that next week we found
out a little bit about the teams that
they're gonna start out with an infinity
war and the movies actually being shot
in a slightly different way so it's not
like your standard Marvel Captain
America Civil War movie where everybody
is around each other starting at the
beginning it states that the Avengers
shall no longer be a private
organization instead they'll operate
under the supervision of a United
Nations panel only when and if that
panel deems it necessary the big thing
they changed with the way they
structured the infinity war storyline is
that they turned it more into a movie
full of vignettes so you have scenes
with a bunch of different teams because
Thanos is going after the gems so you
just have a bunch of different groups
for the Black Order to go fight so
you'll have like Corvus glaive going
after vision who has a couple other
Avengers around him then you'll have a
beanie ma going
after dr. strange with the time gem who
has a couple of the other Avengers
around him so you get the idea the movie
starts out with a couple of different
groups of Avengers then by the end of
the movie we get two scenes like this
where you have them all together in a
more battleworld setting and I know
everybody's wondering about Secret Wars
for Avengers for are we gonna do Secret
Wars will they do the symbiote where's
Captain Marvel and all this if she's
supposed to be so powerful so that's
Avengers 4 but the teams it seems like
they're starting out with in Avengers 3
an infinity war is rocket Groot Drax
Thor Loki so that kind of confirms the
idea that Thor faced plants on the
Milano and he starts out with the
guardians then the other group around
vision is going to be Captain America
Black Widow Falcon in Scarlet Witch
which sort of confirmed stuff that we've
seen from that comic-con trailer you've
all seen those Iron Man Doctor Strange
set pics so it looks like team
spider-man starts out with Wong Iron Man
in spider-man and then separately you
have Hawkeye Winter Soldier war machine
black panther and Hulk which is also
sort of confirmed by the infinity war
footage but the thing is is that later
in that Comic Con footage you saw some
of those characters in vastly different
places we've seen set pics of the Hulk
with Iron Man like it looks like banner
is crying into Tony's shoulder so this
is probably after the battle and most of
them are still on earth it doesn't
address any of the battle world setting
when most of them go into outer space so
you have each of these teams that you
start out with built around the infinity
gems that are already on earth and it
seems like there are a couple characters
that just jump over to other people's
teams and that might serve as the
connective tissue that connects all
these different storylines now getting
to Avengers for now obviously most
people will survive two Avengers for
they have a problem with killing people
in these big Marvel movies so we just
got confirmation the Captain Marvel is
actually going to be in that fourth
Avengers film but she's not going to be
an infinity war why is that she's
supposed to be the most powerful new
character that Kevin Feige has been
hyping up villains of this will be the
first MCU appearance of the scrolls
we've got our filmmakers Anna Boden and
Ryan Fleck working hard
we announced that we we gave it a little
tidbits today but we started filming
earlier next year and and almost
everything we do almost every decision
we make somewhere in the back of our
head we're thinking about Hall H at
Comic Con so I think there are a couple
big reasons for that one the Captain
Marvel movie will drop in between the
Avengers films that'll tell her origin
story but it's set back during the 90s
we learned back at Comic Con she'll be
facing the Kree in the Skrulls like
they'll be doing a version of the
kree-skrull war that'll have something
to do with the way she gets her powers
we're gonna see Nick Fury lose one of
his eyes like samuel l.jackson will be a
big character in the movie he'll have
two eyes when the movie starts he'll
have that eyepatch by the end of it but
if that's taking place in the 90s then
why isn't she around when infinity war
happens probably because she's in deep
outer space something happens at the end
of the Captain Marvel movie and she
either stays out there to clean up the
mess or police that part of the galaxy
but really the other reason why I think
that they're waiting until the fourth
Avengers movies to introduce her is
because they want to develop the
character a little bit and they can do
that in her own film they can tell you
who she is what her powers are what she
can do so that when she comes into
Avengers 4 they don't have to spend all
this time explaining who she is and
what's going on they can just drop her
in and she can just start beating the
out of the Black Order and Thanos
so she's sort of like the upgrade that
the Avengers get after they get their
asses handed to them by Thanos and his
children so should go without saying
that even though the Avengers are gonna
be really badass Avengers 3 is all about
Thanos collecting the gems he has to
take them from the Avengers meaning that
when he assembles the Infinity Gauntlet
it'll only be because he kicked their
asses
[Music]
put a smile on my face so there's no
question about the Avengers being
defeated during Avengers 3 but Avengers
4 is all about them finally defeating
him so that's where Captain Marvel comes
in to help out well let me know in the
comments what are all your Captain
Marvel theories do you think we'll hear
them refer to her during infinity war or
do you think they won't even bother
because there's already so many
characters and so much stuff going on
and again like I said it sounds more
like the infinity war teaser trailer
will drop when we get a little bit
closer to Thor so I'm expecting it later
in October you know maybe like the week
before Thor comes but I'll just post
updates if we hear anything new about
that I know everybody wants that trailer
just give me the footage I want the
footage a lot of you been requesting
infinity gem videos I'll start to do
more infinity war videos as we get
closer to Thor and we start learning
more stuff about the infinity war movies
but there's a whole bunch of comic book
stuff coming up it's all gonna be
awesome congratulations to the latest
Thor giveaway winner Brenda Britt oh
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details you can click here to
watch that Metallica Punisher trailer
again and you can click here for
brand-new Thor Ragnarok thank you so
much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you